IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT
GAME, RESUMAYDAY
RESUMAYDAY.
THANKS TO YOUTUBE SOME
PEOPLE HAVE THE GOTTEN THE
IDEA THAT THE TICKET TO
LANDING THEIR DREAM JOB IS A
QUIRKY HOMEMADE VIDEO
RESUME.
IT WORKED FOR ONE PERSON,
PROBABLY ONCE.
SO WHERE NOT LET THEIR
EMPLOYERS SEE HOW FILTHY
YOUR LIVING ROOM IS BEHIND
YOU.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
QUESTIONABLE VIDEO RESUMES
AND FOR 250 POINTS I WANT
YOU TO EVALUATE THEM AS JOB
CANDIDATES.
FIRST UP THIS BAREFOOTED
ACOUSTIC GUITAR HOPEFUL.
>> Chris: NATASHA, WHAT KIND OF
RECOMMENDATION WOULD YOU
GIVE THIS GUY.
>> TENDER LOVER.
>> Chris: DOUG, DO YOU HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION FOR HIS NEXT
EMPLOYER.
>> PROBABLY NOT.
>> Chris: OKAY.
HOW IS DOUG WINNING, I FEEL
LIKE HE'S NOT ANSWERING
ANYTHING.
>> HE'S TO THE-- THE
GUY-- THE GUY IS WHO JUST
SAID THAT ISN'T JUST WINNING,
HE'S DESTROYING.
>> Chris: YES.
>> HE IS DESTROYING.
>> WHY, WHY, YOU KNOW, SHOW
OFF, YOU KNOW.
I LIKE TO LET THE KIDS HAVE
A CHANCE.
>> Chris: OH, MAN.
LAST ONE, HERE'S A YOUTUBE
PERSONALITY WHO PUT TOGETHER
THIS RESUME TO BE A
HOLLYWOOD ACTOR.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER, I'M
SHOENICE. I CAN JUST ACT.
I CAN BE A 35 AREA OLD IDIOT...
A 22-YEAR-OLD COLLEGE KID...
OR JACK NICHOLSON.
YOU CAN'T HANDLE THE TRUTH.
>> Chris: I THINK THE MOST
SHOCKING THING ABOUT THIS VIDEO
IS HEARING THAT HE'S 35.
>> SHOT ON A COMPUTER AT THE
LIBRARY.
>> Chris: IN TERMS OF PAST
EXPERIENCE, WHAT ROLE DOES
YOU THINK YOU WITH SEE ON
HIS IMBD PAGE, TOM LENNON.
>> GASSY KLAN MEMBER AT RALLY.
>> Chris: POINTS.